[Music]
i am sharing barney's breakfast do you
like it
how about you
would you like to comment on this
picture old woman barney likes rocks
asthma inhalers and his grandmother's
food
will you come to my secret shed and like
him
[Music]
that was barney's wake up routine
okay friend request friend request
[Music]
there's two kinds of people dad
the ones who have a bee bot
and the ones who don't hey guys oh sorry
i'm in your shot oh i have a filter for
that
really you need a bee bot to have a
social life yeah dad kind of i don't
want you addicted to some device
yeah though
[Music]
you got me one
welcome to the show hi barney i'm your
best friend out of my box
what are you doing
barney your bee bot is like super weird
i am barney's bee bop will you come to
my secret shed and like him
no no
okay ron a bunch of your code is missing
you're supposed to know everything about
me hair brown height 411 511 would be
better girls would not laugh at you hey
making friends is what he's for friend
request friend request if he can't do
that he's like literally pointless oh
rose is pulling my head off you can't
pull his head up we'll get in trouble
okay
i cannot pull his head off
i have no mega safety controls and stuff
copy him find that code
i'd better look into that you think
i'm not leaving you behind
they will send you to the crusher we'll
go to the crusher together no crushing
is not fun
not fun
where is it find the road we don't need
anyone else i currently have one friend
that is sad and also tragic
no problem
are we having fun with me
them
[Music]
maybe turn it off and on again
[Music]
you